what would be something uh some advice
you would give like somebody who has got
a little traction in their city but
don't really kind of you know
know what to do to like kind of break
through and like kind of because i feel
like you had a moment where i feel like
you really were
i guess
a california-like secret or a west coast
secret i think and i feel like you broke
through around the time the one up top
album came out i feel like that was kind
of
break
your
a moment
uh what i say is the advice i give is uh
probably
i mean you know the best out of
everything i'd have done in my career
just moving around moving around jumping
on the freeways and um i say that just
you know because uh
you're gonna be the most hated in your
city
just do the political reasons alone
whether i'm saying just political even
if you're not a politician even if you
ain't politicking right right due to
political reasons they don't hate you
but as soon as you i'm saying skip a
couple states or skip a couple cities
over it's like um
it's like
it's like you're a foreigner and i'm
seeing me you you they smell it on you
you're a little different and everybody
gravitate towards that so uh the same
way i was a sacramento [ __ ] i migrated
to the bay bay area fell in love with it
by the way people who aren't like real
fans of yours still think you're from
the beginning
some people yo you know the base lit
mines i'm like mazzy is from southern
man oh my oh my
hey they tried to bot but just every
single [ __ ] stocked in sacramento
everything is debate like you know it's
not that nah nah valley love valley love
shout out to the yay area but uh [ __ ]
migrated to the yay area they fell in
love with a [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm saying
jumped a couple cities over [ __ ] ended
up in l.a they fell in love with a [ __ ]
i'm not a politician in la mcme um so
it's easy for the key ways to function
with me it's easy for the bloods to lock
in with me yeah i'm seeing me um [ __ ]
you know jump on a flint night and i'm
saying go [ __ ] with kansas city they
fall in love with a [ __ ] arizona it
just starts spreading but i think the
whole thing is um you know uh just just
spreading your wings man getting outside
of your your circumference getting
outside of your comfort zone and uh to
the point where it'd be like this [ __ ]
gotta work if you at home you got
options and your and
stop rapping and go get a job it's that
comfort it's that confidence you get out
i tell everybody move out of your
[ __ ] hometown
cause then it's gotta you gotta make it
work
because there's no not options you can't
go to your mom's house that's not
optional yeah ain't no comfort zone
you've got to so uh that's my whole
thing is just jumping on that freeway
man putting miles putting miles on that
automobile that's the illest man i tell
that [ __ ] to people all the time i i
talk to so many people
you know i got homies of mine who i've
been trying to get to leave their
hometown specifically phoenix arizona uh
like yo man get the [ __ ] out of there
like that's your house yeah like yo i
ain't know phoenix was your house i was
trying to figure out why you were
celebrating your birthday in phoenix
arizona cause i'm from there i ain't no
i was asleep
okay you just woke my game up but it's
like i got all the baddest [ __ ]
you're right
i give it to you you're right
no lie huh hey my wife's from phoenix so
yes you're right i married one of them